This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个栏目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的有执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身铠甲。这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须时刻全副武装。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的检测结果给某人，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。和焦虑。让自己经历一些磨难，你会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。
On the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed I will be his last target.
在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓我要成为他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
他休想就这样逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《相信女朋友们，相信我，宝贝》（Trust the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. What is a more glamorous in like a uniquely non-glamorous way? What is a more quintessential, chaotic but wonderful 20-something experience, than solo traveling, packing everything up for a few weeks, maybe a few months, a year, and just exploring the world by yourself, backpacking across Europe,
欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。当然，我们要剖析二十几岁的心理。有什么比这更迷人，却又以一种独特的不迷人方式存在的呢？有什么比一个人独自旅行，花几周、几个月甚至一年把所有东西打包好，独自探索世界，背包游欧洲，更能体现二十几岁那种充满 quintessential（典型）、混乱却又美好的体验呢？
going to Bali for a month to do yoga, catching like, a last minute train to the other side of the country or a flight to the other side of the world to find yourself to find memories to test yourself solo traveling just feels like this really important thing that we need to do in our 20s almost like a ride of passage i would say i will meet some of the most incredible independent self-assured 20-something year olds and i can just tell they have solo traveled. I can just tell that they know exactly who they are more than most of us because they have had this very unique, important experience of having to truly trust themselves, of knowing that there is no one else in that moment who can make a decision for them, who can be their
去巴厘岛呆上一个月练瑜伽，临时买张去国家另一头的火车票或去世界另一头寻找自我的机票，去寻找回忆，去考验自己——独自旅行感觉就像是我们在二十几岁时必须做的一件非常重要的事情，几乎可以说是成人礼。我可以说，我会遇到一些最不可思议、独立且自信的二十几岁年轻人，我一眼就能看出他们曾经独自旅行过。我一眼就能看出他们比大多数人更清楚自己是谁，因为他们有过这种非常独特、重要的经历：必须真正信任自己，知道在那个时刻没有别人可以为他们做决定，没有别人可以做他们的常伴，也没有别人能在特定情况下帮助他们。这是一种完全自主的、有时甚至是可怕的体验。
constant company, who can help them in certain situations. It is this like entirely self-directed and at times scary situation. That is also equally. magnificent. And I've heard from so many of you our wonderful listeners who basically credit solo traveling with transforming their identity and their personality during this decade, especially at very pivotal points, you know, post-breakup, post-graduation between jobs, a lot more of us are using travel and doing it on our own to really be this experience that brings us into a new chapter of our lives and it's just absolutely remarkable. I am such a big advocate for doing this.
这也同样是宏伟壮丽的。我听过许多你们这些优秀的听众说，你们基本上将独自旅行归功于它在这一十年里重塑了你们的身份和个性，尤其是在非常关键的节点，比如分手后、毕业后、换工作之间。我们越来越多的人开始利用旅行，并且独自出行，让这真正成为带我们进入人生新篇章的体验，这简直太卓越了。我非常大力倡导这样做。
You know, when I was 20, I solo traveled to Europe from Australia and just spent hours walking around to different sites and churches and getting lost. I actually remember back then, I had like an iPhone 10 or like an iPhone 11 and I didn't want to pay for a data plan. So when I was at my hostel with Wi-Fi, I would literally point my phone in the direct that I would want to go. And I kid you not, I would be like, okay, where is the sun right now? Is the sun behind me? Like, when I'm pointing in this direction, it's the sun to my left, to my right. As long as the sun remains in that position, I can just keep walking in that way and I'll find
你知道，当我20岁的时候，我从澳大利亚独自去欧洲旅行，花了几个小时到处走到不同的景点和教堂，然后迷路了。我其实还记得当时，我用的是iPhone 10还是iPhone 11左右的手机，我不想付流量费。所以当我在有Wi-Fi的旅舍时，我真的会把手机指向我想去的方向。我向你保证，我会想：“好吧，现在太阳在哪里？太阳在我身后吗？就像我指向这个方向时，太阳是在我的左边还是右边？”只要太阳保持那个位置，我就可以一直朝那个方向走，然后我就会发现自己到达了目的地。当然，老实说，我还是会迷路。我永远不知道自己要去哪里，直到我像误打误撞一样走进一家有Wi-Fi的麦当劳。
myself getting there. And of course, you know, I would get lost. I would never really know where I was going, to be completely honest, until I, like, stumbled into a McDonald's with Wi-Fi. but it was just such a beautiful experience and I really learned to be confident and self-directed. I watched the sunrise in Amsterdam. I had dinner with strangers. I got a tattoo and then I got another one. And those are the kinds of memories that you tell your children or you tell your friends in the nursing home. They are the ones that form the foundation for our life.
但这真是一段非常美好的经历，我真正学会了自信和自主。我在阿姆斯特丹看日出。我和陌生人共进晚餐。我纹了一个身，然后又纹了一个。这些就是你会讲给你的孩子们听，或者讲给养老院里的朋友们听的那种回忆。正是它们构成了我们生活的基石。
One big misconception that I really want to address is that solo traveling does have to be this huge multi-week, multi-month, multi-location, expensive trip. And I don't think it has to be. It can be as simple as a weekend away by yourself or a camping trip just to, you know, two hours away. That is something that I also have loved doing, you know, packing up my tent in my car and just spending three days alone by myself to clear my mind. My cousin was recently texting me like a couple of days ago actually about a solo camping
我真的很想纠正的一个巨大误解是，独自旅行必须是一次跨越多周、多月、多地点、极其昂贵的宏大旅行。我不认为必须如此。它可以很简单，比如独自度过一个周末，或者仅仅去一个离家两小时车程的地方露营。这也是我很喜欢做的事情，把帐篷打包在车里，独自度过三天来清醒一下头脑。我的表姐最近几天还给我发短信，谈起她最近的一次独自露营之旅，离家只有两个小时车程，仅仅持续了大约48小时。
trip that she did only two hours away from home for only like 48 hours. And even in that short span of time, she was like, this is amazing. I feel so liberated. I feel so free. I just think there are so many other ways to experience the joy and the gift that solo traveling has without breaking the bank, without feeling, you know, really, really out of your comfort zone to begin with. It's definitely something that needs to be, I think, talked about more instead of this glamour. luxurious, often expensive ride of passage, you can literally do it in your own neighbourhood. And I think people, because of that, but also just because of the wider accessibility of travel, are really picking it up, especially post-COVID as well.
即便是在这么短的时间内，她也说：“这太棒了。我感到无比解放。我感到无比自由。”我只是觉得，有很多其他方式可以体验独自旅行带来的快乐和馈赠，而不用花光积蓄，也不用一开始就感到真的极度超出你的舒适区。我认为这绝对是一件需要被更多人讨论的事情，而不是把它看作一种光鲜亮丽、奢侈且通常昂贵的成人礼，你完全可以在自己的社区里做到这一点正因为如此，同时也因为旅行变得更加普及，人们真的越来越喜欢独自旅行，尤其是在新冠疫情之后。
I think a lot of us are not so keen to wait until someone else is ready to do the things we want to do. A lot of us have realized that if you wait and you wait and you wait until the time is right until you have company you know a pandemic could begin things can get in the way and you're going to miss the opportunity there was actually a 42% increase in people taking solo trips over the past two years and you know now solo travelers according to this really amazing um research done by solo travel statistics because of course there are people who are measuring this solo travelers make up 11% of the overall total market. And 84% of those solo travelers are women.
我想我们中的很多人都不太愿意一直等到别人准备好了，再去干自己想做的事。许多人已经意识到，如果你一等再等，等到时机成熟，等到有人陪你——你知道，可能一场大流行病会爆发，各种事情会横加阻挠，然后你就会错过这个机会。实际上，在过去两年里，进行独行的人数增加了42%。你知道，现在根据独行统计数据（solo travel statistics）这项非常了不起的研究显示，因为确实有人在统计这些数据，独行旅客占了整个市场总份额的11%。而这些独行旅客中有84%是女性。
So it's likely that if you go out looking for adventure in a foreign country or just up the coast, you will find other people similar to you doing this same thing, looking for something, wanting it to be self-directed, no longer wanting to wait until someone else will raise their hand and say, yeah, okay, I'll come with you. So today I want to talk about this increasingly common experience, the psychology of solo traveling and how uniquely beneficial it can be to us during our 20s. There will definitely be hard times, there will be lonely times, but we also get to experience
所以，如果你去一个陌生国家或者仅仅是去海岸边寻找冒险，你很有可能会发现其他和你相似的人也在做同样的事：寻找着什么，希望一切由自己主导，再也不想等着别人举手说：“好吧，我跟你一起去。”所以今天我想谈谈这种日益普遍的经历——独自旅行的心理学，以及它在我们的二十几岁对我们有着多么独特而有益的影响。这其中肯定会有艰难的时刻，会有孤独的时刻，但我们也能体验到这种自由。我们能体验到一种独特的——我不知道用什么词最合适——解放感、蜕变感。我想只有当你身处那些时刻并且正在经历它时，你才会几乎对这种感觉上瘾，而且看起来我们中的很多人确实如此。我还想讨论一些你可能会遇到的独特挑战，以及如何在心理上克服它们。当我们返回家中时会发生什么？当独自旅行者被召回时会发生什么？这里有太多东西可以讨论了。这个话题比你想象的要深奥得多。
this freedom. We get to experience this unique sense of, I don't know what the right word is, liberation, transformation. I think it's only when you're in those moments and you're experiencing. experiencing it that you're you almost become addicted to the sensation and seems like a lot of us are. I also want to talk about some of the unique challenges that you might encounter, but psychologically how to overcome them. And what happens when we return home? What happens when the solo traveler is called back off the road? There is so much to discuss in this. This topic is so much
所以，废话不多说，让我们切入独自旅行的心理学。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以摆脱主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
deeper than you can imagine. So without further ado, let us get into the psychology of solo traveling. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to live. look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-P-Cent（2%）。在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的其中一个地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两次小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的来龙去脉，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
大谈80年代的快克可卡因（crack）。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，不过为了让大家知道。我的意思是，到了这个时候，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在台面上了。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人而言。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，当你活在世上的时候，还是因为你害怕才去做一个好人？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难抉择》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法院听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的检测结果给某人，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detainty.
来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在I-Heart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。我们很多人都深深地被独自旅行所吸引，我想这主要是因为它感觉如此神圣。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura O'clock. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the I-Heart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. A lot of us feel deeply drawn to solo travel specifically, I think because of how sacred it feels.
这就是我会如何形容它。正如我之前所说，有一种几乎像是成人礼的感觉附着在这种同样可怕但最终回报丰厚的体验上。在我们的生活中，我们究竟有多少次真正有机会独自一人，在一切事情上真正依靠自己？你知道，我们到底有多少次能够真正主导自己生活中的大部分决定？我们大多数人，包括我自己在内，可以说，我们总是被朋友、家人、爱人、同事环绕，而且我们也身处一个非常舒适、熟悉且易于导航的环境中。
And that's how I would describe it. There is, as I said before, almost a ride-of-passage feeling that is attached to this equally scary but ultimately rewarding experience. How often in our lives do we actually ever get the opportunity to be truly alone, to be truly dependent on ourselves for everything? You know, how often are we actually able to call most of the shots in our life? Most of us, myself included, I would say, we are constantly surrounded by friends, family, loved ones, colleagues, and we also are in a very comfortable
但独自旅行彻底打乱了这一切。首先，当你独自旅行时，你身处一个你并不一定熟悉的地方。然后，你移除了你的支持网络。接着，你可能还会加入一种你不会说的语言。但与此同时，伴随而来的也是一种兴奋。明天会带来什么，有着无限的可能性。我将选择做什么？它是新奇的。它是可怕的。它是令人畏惧的。上一次你在当前的日常生活中真正有这种感觉是什么时候？
environment that is familiar and that is really easy to navigate. But solo travel really throws all of that up in the air. Firstly, you're in a place that you don't necessarily know when you solo travel. Then you remove your support network. Then you might add in, you know, a language that you don't speak. But also with that, there is an excitement. There is this unlimited possibility of what's tomorrow going to bring. What am I going to choose to do? It's novel. It's scary. It's scary. and when was the last time that you actually felt that way in your current routine? So what is it about solo travelling that is so alluring other than what I have just described? Well, there was a 2015 report from the International Journal for Tourism Research that looked into
那么，除了我刚描述的之外，独自旅行究竟有什么如此诱人的地方？好吧，国际旅游研究杂志（International Journal for Tourism Research）在2015年有一份报告对此进行了调查。它想知道为什么人们突然对这种经历如此着迷？它发现，大多数独自旅行者的动力源于以下几点之一：
this. It wanted to know why are people suddenly so drawn to this experience? And what it found was that the majority of solo travellers are motivated by one of the following things. they are motivated by the need for a feeling of freedom, by a desire to escape or a desire to find themselves. So a feelings of freedom, a desire to escape, or a desire to find ourselves, which honestly all sound like pretty much the same thing wrapped into one. There was another study from 2021 that found something very, very similar. when this researcher interviewed a number of people who were solo travelers who had solo traveled in the past year or two, what they said motivated them was very similar, but besides those previous inspirational motivations, besides those previous intentions, they also said that it was the flexibility,
他们的动力来自于对自由感的需要、对逃避的渴望或对寻找自我的渴望。因此，对自由感的追求、对逃避的渴望或对寻找自我的渴望，老实说，听起来其实都差不多是一回事。2021年的另一项研究也发现了非常非常相似的结果。当这位研究人员采访了许多在过去一两年里独自旅行的独自旅行者时，他们所说的动力非常相似，但除了前面那些鼓舞人心的动机、除了那些先前的意图之外，他们还表示，是灵活性、
it was the promise of a transformative experience, and this anticipated self-discovery that was really, really motivating. So maybe you can relate to that with your own solo travel ambitions. We are seeking out the promise of knowing ourselves better. And this is particularly influential after you've just been through something really tough or life-changing like a breakup, for example, or you've just been made redundant, or you've graduated. You are, I think, particularly poised for growth at that moment.
是变革性体验的承诺，以及这种对自我发现的期待，真正构成了巨大的动力。所以也许你可以从你自己的独自旅行野心中找到共鸣。我们在寻找更好地了解自己的承诺。在你刚刚经历了一些非常艰难或改变人生的大事之后，比如分手，或者你刚被裁员，或者你刚毕业，这种影响尤其深远。我认为你在那个时刻特别蓄势待发，准备好迎接成长，而旅行真正把这一点激发出来了。
moment and travel really, really brings that out. I think that it's actually really important to do after one of those moments. You can't just go back to, you know, living in everyday life. After you graduate, you know that normalcy is gone after your breakup, after you've been made redundant. Everything about your current everyday reality has shifted. And I think giving yourself time to go and solo travel through that allows you to kind of jump into the next chapter of whatever life is going to bring you being more confident being more self-assured genuinely just knowing what you want and knowing how to speak about that knowing how to say that some of us do have more of a propensity for solo travel than others and it's actually influenced by this personality trait called
我认为在经历这些时刻之一后去做这件事实际上非常重要。你不能只是回到过日常生活中去。在你毕业后，你知道那种正常状态在分手后、在被裁员后已经不复存在了。你目前日常现实的一切都发生了转变。我认为给自己时间去进行独自旅行，能让你带着更多的自信、更多的坚定、真正知道自己想要什么以及知道如何表达这一点、知道如何说出这些来，跃入无论生活将带给你什么样的新篇章。我们有些人比其他人更倾向于独自旅行，这实际上受一种被称为“对体验的开放性”的性格特质的影响。
an openness to experience i don't think that's a surprise but you might be familiar with with this trait, it's one of the big five personality traits. And if you are someone who measures high on this characteristic, on this openness to experience, you are typically more curious. You are more independent, adaptable, willing to try new ideas, new values, new emotions, new experiences, and you are more adventurous. So this openness to experience combined with something that we call high self-efficacy, which basically refers to our belief in our ability to influence our reality and to influence the outcomes that we would like. Those two things essentially allow us to really trust in our agency, but also to feel quite
我想这并不令人意外，但你可能对这个特质很熟悉，它是大五人格特质之一。如果你在这个特征（即对体验的开放性）上得分较高，你通常会更具好奇心。你更加独立、适应力强，愿意尝试新的想法、新的价值观、新的情绪、新的体验，并且你更具冒险精神。因此，这种对体验的开放性与我们称之为“高自我效能感”的东西结合在一起，后者基本上指的是我们对自己影响现实能力以及实现我们所期望结果的能力的信念。这两点基本上使我们能够真正信任自己的自主性，同时也对拥有这些体验感到相当充满热情。
passionate about having these experiences. And it makes for the ideal solo traveler. I will say the final big reason I personally like solo traveling that isn't related to finding yourself that isn't related to an openness to experience. And it might sound self-relevant. but it's basically just that you don't have to consider other people in your plans. And if you are someone who is very hyper-independent, maybe even impatient like I am at times, that can be such a big factor in what is influencing us to solo travel. I am already someone who finds travel to be kind of anxiety-inducing. You know, I have fun, I love it once I get there.
这就造就了理想的独自旅行者。我要说的是，我个人喜欢独自旅行的最后一个重大原因与寻找自我无关，与对体验的开放性无关。这听起来可能有点自私，但它基本上就是你不需要在计划中考虑其他人。如果你是一个高度独立、甚至有时像我一样没有耐心的人，这可能会成为影响我们独自旅行的一个巨大因素。我本来就是一个觉得旅行会引发某种焦虑的人。你知道，我玩得很开心，一旦到了那里我就很爱旅行。
But I do find like I do need to go up my own pace, my own speed. I want to see things that other people might not. And sometimes I like to go back to the same places. I'm a very particular kind of traveler. And I appreciate that I'm also quite indulgent. And that might be like indulgent with my time. Like I want to go slow. I want to just really bask in the experiences.
但我确实觉得我需要按照自己的节奏、自己的速度前进。我想看一些其他人可能不会关注的东西。有时我想回到相同的地方。我是一种非常特殊的旅行者。而且我很感激我也相当随性放任。这可能表现为对时间的放任——比如我想慢下来。我只想真正沉浸在体验中。
And that's probably annoying for people to travel with. But it also means that people who travel differently to me, I find it kind of frustrating sometimes, having to compromise for something that is so uniquely, like, traveling is a selfish experience. It is a self-driven experience. You know, you've already spent all this money to get somewhere, at least coming from Australia, if I want to go to Europe or Africa or North America, it's going to take me at least 15 to 24 hours. And it's going to cost me a lot of money.
和这样的人一起旅行可能会很烦人。但这也意味着，对于那些旅行方式与我不同的人，我有时会觉得挺沮丧，因为不得不为了某些极其独特的事情而去妥协——旅行其实是一种自私的体验。它是一种自我驱动的体验。你知道的，你已经花了这么多钱去某个地方，至少从澳大利亚出发的话，如果我想去欧洲、非洲或北美，将花费我至少15到24个小时。并且它会花掉我很多钱。
So once I get there, it's kind of like I don't want to have to consult a group of friends or every single member of my family, any time I want to eat or book accommodation or spontaneously change my plans. And I think that's really sometimes another really valuable thing to consider. Like, if this is such a personal and, I know, I said selfish, but personal experience, sometimes you don't want to share it with someone else. This actually brings up a memory I have, not even a memory. basically when I was 15, I went to New York with my family for Christmas because my mom is American
所以一旦我到了那里，基本上就变成：我不想每次我想吃饭、订住宿或自发改变计划时，都要去征求一群朋友或我家族中每一个成员的意见。我认为这有时确实是另一个非常值得考虑的有价值的事情。如果这是一个如此个人化、我知道我说了自私但这就是个人化的体验，有时你真的不想和别人分享。这其实让我想起了一个回忆，甚至算不上回忆。基本上，在我15岁的时候，我和家人一起去纽约过圣诞节，因为我妈妈是美国人，
and we were kind of visiting some of her family as well. And I was a very avid journaler at the time. I wrote a journal entry every single night. And recently I was looking back through my old journals from that time because I was just doing some reminiscing with my book being announced. And I found an entry from that time and it said in all caps, quote, you do not like traveling with other people do not do this again when you become an adult do not travel with other people and i just had to laugh about it i was like that is so funny that 15 year old jemma already kind of knew what was up i like showed it to my boyfriend and he was like yeah absolutely
我们顺便也去看望了她的一些家人。我当时是一个非常狂热的写日记的人。我每天晚上都写一篇日记。最近我一直在翻看我那个时期的旧日记，因为随着我的书的官宣，我一直在怀念过去。我找到了当时的一条日记，里面全是大写字母写着：“引述：你根本不喜欢和别人一起旅行，等你成年后千万不要再这样做了，不要和别人一起旅行。”我当时忍不住笑了出来，心想：真是太有趣了，15岁的杰玛其实已经有点看透了。我把它给我男朋友看，他说：“完全正确，就像我们一起旅行时，我也需要我的日子去独自做我自己的事。”和我的朋友们旅行也是一样，并不是说我不喜欢这样做，但我绝对需要在其中拥有那个独处的空间。
like even when we travel together i need my days to just go and do my own thing same with when i travel with my friends it's not like i don't like doing it but i definitely need that solo space within that And this really brings me to my first major point as to why solo traveling is so valuable to do during your 20s. And it's that it makes you confident in your own choices and it really ensures that you get to prioritize the experiences that you want to have. If you are someone who is, for example, you know, maybe a people pleaser, that experience of getting to prioritize what you want to do can be so liberating. Sometimes it's like one of the first times that we've ever been allowed to just, and we've ever given ourselves permission, I guess, to just do what best suits us without having to carry the burden of thinking about other people's preferences. It can almost bring you to tears sometimes, you know, getting to eat lunch when you want, watching the sunset on a random day because you want to. it's like the weight of always considering what would make other people happy and having to
这真的让我想到了我的第一个主要观点：为什么独自旅行在二十几岁时如此宝贵。那就是它能让你对自己的选择充满自信，并真正确保你能够优先考虑自己想要拥有的体验。如果你是一个习惯于迎合他人的人（people pleaser），那么这种能够优先考虑自己想做的事情的体验会是如此解放。有时这就像是我们第一次被允许，也是我们第一次给予自己许可去只做最适合我们自己的事，而不必背负考虑其他人偏好的沉重负担。有时甚至会让你感动得流泪，你知道的，想什么时候吃午饭就什么时候吃午饭，因为你想看日落就在随性的一天去看日落。
juggle all of their contradictory preferences is gone the burden is really lifted and i think you'll be surprised to see how much your relationship with yourself improves as a result of this suddenly you really learn to listen to yourself you know what it feels like to just have it your way and that feels really fucking good. I think that is why women especially find a lot of freedom in solo travel, especially if you were an eldest daughter or came from a large family or felt a lot of expectations from your parents when you were younger. Solo traveling is this unique space where you are actually rewarded for knowing what you want and doing it. And isn't that so contradictory to you know the childhood environments and the teenage environments that we were raised in? In fact, you know,
那种总是考虑什么能让别人开心、不得不兼顾所有人相互矛盾的偏好的重担消失了，负担真的被卸下了。我想你会惊讶地发现，因此你与自己的关系得到了多么大的改善。突然之间，你真正学会了倾听自己，你知道顺从自己的心意是什么感觉，而那感觉真的他妈太棒了。我想这就是为什么女性尤其能在独自旅行中找到很多自由，特别是如果你是长女、来自大家庭，或者在年轻时从父母那里感受到了很多期望。独自旅行是一个独特的空间，在这里，你知道自己想要什么并去践行它，实际上会受到奖励。这难道不与我们成长过程中的童年环境和青少年环境如此矛盾吗？事实上，
to bring another psychology study into the mix because we can never have too many. There was a paper from 2023, so last year that found that traveling alone means you actually experience the sensations and the moments of your trip more deeply because you are less distracted by a second person. You actually have the chance to meet new people, chat to new people, pay attention to the small things, you know, as you walk the streets you are naturally more aware, both from a safety perspective, but I think that with that awareness, it brings more moments of noticing. And that in itself, the necessity of being more aware of your surroundings, it really promotes
为了再引入一个心理学研究，因为我们永远不会嫌研究太多。2023年（也就是去年）有一篇论文发现，独自旅行意味着你实际上能更深切地体验到你旅途中的感官感受和时刻，因为你不会被第二个人分心。你实际上有机会结识新的人、和新的人聊天、关注微小的事情，当你走在街上时，你自然会更加警觉，既从安全的角度出发，但我认为伴随着这种警觉，会带来更多留心观察的时刻。而这本身——需要更多关注周围环境的必要性——真正促进了活在当下，这对于我们从旅行中获得的心理和精神体验是极为美妙的。
being present, which is really fantastic for the emotional and mental experience that we get from traveling. We also know that this experience really allows you to prove to yourself that you can do hard things, things that you never really imagined yourself doing. Let me tell you a story about how I had this very experience, this very realization that I was a lot tougher and smarter than I thought I was because of solo traveling. So one uni break, I was traveling somewhere and I can't even remember specifically where I was traveling to because I was coming back. I was returning home to Australia and I had booked,
我们也知道，这段经历确实能让你向自己证明，你可以做困难的事情，做那些你从未真正想象过自己能做的事情。让我给你讲个故事，讲讲我是如何有这种经历的——这种由于独自旅行而发现自己比想象中更坚强、更聪明的意识。所以某个大学假期，我正在去某处的路上，我甚至不记得具体是去哪里旅行了，因为我当时正在回程途中。我正在返回澳大利亚的家中，我订了，
of course, you know, the cheapest flight possible. I remember it was like $800 return, I think to Amsterdam actually. I was going through Amsterdam to Europe and some other places. So $800 return from Sydney to Amsterdam and then back. And you have to remember, this is firstly Australian dollars, so a lot cheaper than like the US dollar or like pounds or euros or whatever. Very, very cheap at the time for a 24 hour trip. Like that's how long the flight took. Anyways, the catch of this cheap flight was that I had to spend 15 hours in Taiwan overnight. And at this point, I had completely run out of money on my international card.
当然，你知道的，是最便宜的机票。我记得往返大约是800澳元，我想其实是去阿姆斯特丹。我是经由阿姆斯特丹去欧洲和其他地方的。所以从悉尼到阿姆斯特丹往返只要800澳元。你得记住，首先这是澳大利亚元，所以比美元、英镑或欧元等要便宜得多。当时对于一个24小时的行程来说，非常非常便宜。飞行时间就是这么长。无论如何，这张便宜机票的代价是，我必须在台湾过夜停留15个小时。而此时，我的国际卡里的钱已经完全花光了。
I only had one $50 American bill in my shoe, like a $50 American note. that my mom was like, always keep this in the bottom of your shoe just in case. Thank you, mum, for reminding me to do that. Well, so I'd stayed in this, I was staying in this small three-room motel. I couldn't stay in the airport for whatever reason. I had to leave the airport. So I was staying in this three-room hotel motel thing. And I paid for it before the start of my trip, did not think about the fact that I would need to get a taxi to the airport and that I would need to eat dinner. You know, This was a 15-hour layover and I didn't have any money. So I remember, like, sneaking into, there was a wedding banquet.
我的鞋里只有一张50美元的纸币，就像一张50美元的纸币，我妈妈当时说：“把这个放在鞋底，以防万一。”谢谢妈妈提醒我这么做。好吧，所以我当时住在一家只有三个房间的小汽车旅馆里。无论出于什么原因，我不能呆在机场。我必须离开机场。所以我住在那个三间房的汽车旅馆似的地方。我在旅行开始前就付过钱了，完全没有考虑到我需要坐出租车去机场，而且我还得吃晚饭。你知道，这是一个15小时的中转停留，而我身上一分钱也没有。所以我记得，像潜入一样，那里有一场婚宴。
Like, someone was getting married. There was so many people there. And they had this huge array of food. And I was like, okay, I'm just going to sneak in. And, you know, they're just going to think, like, this random white girl is here. Like, who invited her? But no one's going to question it. I'm just going to eat some food and sneak out.
就像有人在结婚。那里有好多人。他们摆了一大盘食物，我就想：“好吧，我只是要混进去。”然后，“他们只会觉得，这个随机的白人女孩怎么在这里。是谁邀请了她？”但没人会质疑。我只是去吃点东西，然后溜出去。
And luckily that worked. I honestly think that they kind of. of new and they probably just felt really sorry for me and then came the moment when I needed to get a taxi. I had to get a taxi to the airport and I was kind of panicking and I'd gotten the front desk to call me a local taxi. Had no idea how much it was going to be had this $50 note. He drops me off at the airport and I just give him the $50 American note. No idea if it's more, less right on, you know, if he's even going to accept it. And he says, kind of just looked at me and he just was like, okay, and just took the note. And I got my bag out of the
幸运的是，这管用了。我真的觉得他们大概.知道，而且他们可能只是觉得我很可怜，然后就到了我需要打车的时候。我必须打车去机场，我当时有点恐慌，我让前台帮我叫了一辆本地出租车。完全不知道要花多少钱，手里只有那张50美元的纸币。他把我送到机场，我把那50美元的纸币给了他。完全不知道是多是少，正不正合适，甚至不知道他会不会收。然后他看着我，只是说了一句“好”，就收下了那张钞票。我从后备箱拿出行李，
back and he drove off. And it was just the biggest sense of like relief and accomplishment that was like, okay, like I did that hard thing. I also didn't have any internet. I had no money. I just had myself. I couldn't call anyone. I didn't know anyone in Taiwan. It was equally scary, but also the most empowering thing to just realize that, oh, wow, I'm an adult. in this situation and I figured it out and I've never felt so alone but also so self-sufficient and it's that it's those experiences that we are all bound to have when solo traveling that are going to give you lifelong skills such as problem solving such as decision making I often think a lot of us get worried about solo traveling that we're going to have this like gap
然后他开车走了。那真是一种如释重负和获得成就感的最大宣泄，当时我就想：“好吧，我完成了那件难事。”而且我当时没有任何网络。我没有钱。我只有我自己。我无法打电话给任何人。我在台湾谁也不认识。这既同样可怕，但也是最赋予我力量的事情，让我意识到：“哦，哇，我在这种情况下是个成年人了，我把它搞定了，我从来没有感到这么孤独，但也从未感到这么自给自足。”正是这些我们所有人独自旅行时必然会有的经历，会赋予你终身受用的技能，比如解决问题的能力、做决定的能力。我常常觉得我们很多人会担心独自旅行会在简历上留下这样一个“空白期”。如果我是一个雇主，看到二十几岁的人有这样一段巨大的独自旅行经历，或者腾出时间独自去探索，他们绝对会名列我招聘名单的前茅。因为有太多技能是无法教给你的，职场不会教，大学也不会教。我认为生活不仅仅是拥有职业经历，也是关于拥有生活经历。这样的人是最好共事的、最有趣的，通常也是最有驱动力的。所以如果你曾担心：“我花所有时间独自旅行，其他所有人都比我跑得更前面。”其他人——你正在与之比较的那些人，很可能正看着你并心想：“哇，我真希望自己当初也花时间去探索并了解自己。”这就是为什么我认为即使当你处于恋爱关系中、即使当你拥有长期一夫一妻制的伴侣时，独自旅行依然很重要。当然，你知道的，你想要和他们拥有那些时刻、经历和回忆。你想和他们一起旅行。但如果你正处于二十几岁，并且真的很想去某个地方，你的心愿单上有一个你一直想去的地方，你有资源、有时间、有机会。你不应该觉得自己需要等到别人准备好和你一起去，
in our resume if I was an employer and I saw that someone in their 20s had done this huge solo traveling trip or took time off to go and explore by themselves, they are honestly going to be at the top of my list to hire because there's just so many skills that you cannot teach that a workplace won't teach, that a university won't teach. And I think life is more about just having professional experiences and also about having life experiences. Those are the people who are the best to work with, most interesting, often the most driven. So if you ever worry, like, I've taken all this time off to solo travel, everyone else is further ahead than me. Everyone else, those people you're comparing yourself to, are most likely looking at you and being like, wow, I wish that I'd actually taken time to
你可以一个人去，你可以独自做到，不管发生什么，你都不会突然和这个人绑定成一个不可分割的整体。尤其——不是想当个愤世嫉俗的人——但那段关系可能无法维系。明天可能会发生任何事。你们可能会在下个月或接下来的两、三、五年内分手。当你们不再在一起，而旅行的机会已经过去时，就会产生一种“如果”的感觉，一种围绕着你本可以创造的回忆、你本可以培养的技能、你本可以看过的风景的“如果”。
explore and to know myself. This is why I also think that solo traveling continues to be important even when you are in a relationship, even when you have a long-term monogamous partner. Of course, you know, you want to have those moments and experiences and memories with them. You want to travel with them. But if you are in your 20s and you really want to go somewhere, there is a place on your bucket list that you've always wanted to visit. You have the means, you have the time, you have the opportunity. You shouldn't feel like you need to wait until someone else is ready to go with you.
我认为，（虽然）恋爱关系很重要，我们确实在乎某人，但这并不意味着我们需要放弃所有独自旅行的体验，只和他们一起旅行。所以希望我已经提出了继续这样做（通过独自旅行保持独立性）的论据，当你处于恋爱关系中时，这确实能确保你的自我概念——这个关于你是谁的最高阶、最基础的想法——保持得非常非常强大。
you can go alone, you can do it alone, you are not suddenly a paired item with this person no matter what, especially like not to be a cynic, but that relationship could not work. Something could happen tomorrow. You guys could break up next month or in the next two, three, five years. And when you two are no longer together and the opportunity to travel has passed, there is going to be this what if sensation, this what if surrounding the memories you could have made, the skills you could have built, the things you could have seen.
你可以独自前往，你可以独自完成，无论如何你都不会突然和这个人变成一个捆绑的整体，尤其——这不是为了唱反调——这段关系也可能会破裂。明天可能会发生什么事。你们下个月、或者在未来两、三、五年内可能会分手。而当你们不再在一起，旅行的机会也已经过去时，就会有一种“如果当初”的感觉，这种“如果当初”围绕着本可以创造的回忆、本可以培养的技能、本可以看到的事物。
And I think that, you know, a relationship is important and we do care about someone. It doesn't mean that we need to give up all of our solo experiences and only do it with them. So hopefully I've made an argument for continuing to do this, you know, maintaining your independence through solo traveling, when you're in a relationship, it really ensures that your self-concept, this like overarching, fundamental idea of who you are, that that remains very, very strong.
我认为，你知道，一段关系很重要，我们也确实在乎某人。但这并不意味着我们需要放弃所有独自的体验，只和他们一起去。所以，我希望我已经为继续这样做提供了一个论据，你知道的，在恋爱关系中通过独自旅行来保持你的独立性，这确实能确保你的自我概念——也就是关于你是谁的这个最基本、最核心的想法——能够保持得非常非常强大。
So this is a really glamorous idea of solo travelling that we've painted so far, one of adventure, of self-discovery, of once-in-a-lifetime moments, but there are also hard moments, moments of doubt and loneliness. And I think that's worth discussing. I think it would be remiss of me to just paint this picture of Sunday. and rainbows and self-discovery, there will be hard times that we inevitably encounter, but we also have a lot of really deeply seated psychological tools to help us get through them. So we're going to talk about that and so much more, along with what happens when we return home.
到目前为止，我们所描绘的独自旅行是一个非常迷人的概念，充满了冒险、自我发现和千载难逢的时刻，但其中也有艰难的时刻、充满怀疑和孤独的时刻。我认为这是值得讨论的。如果我只描绘出一幅阳光、彩虹和自我发现的画面，那我就是失职了，我们不可避免地会遇到艰难时期，但我们内心也有很多根深蒂固的心理工具来帮助我们渡过难关。所以我们将讨论这些以及更多内容，还有当我们回到家时会发生什么。
What is post-solo travel shock? All of that after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
什么是独自旅行后遗症？稍作休息后，我们将探讨所有这些内容。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听《2%》。这就是《2%》。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush to do a little kill.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小基姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小基姆到底有什么关系。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talking about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会精选一个历史时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的话题，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。
Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
你是个好人吗？因为你感到害怕。因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是为了做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow
成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
暴露出她说法中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法院诉讼来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
另外两名经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Doing anything you learn. be tough, even when it has its perks. You know, people who solo travel a lot in their 20s, they will most likely tell you how rewarding it is. But if you dig a little deeper, some of the other things they may tell you to essentially be prepared for is the loneliness, the decision fatigue, the exhaustion, the fear of the unknown, maybe safety concerns, wanting to come home early. And also, I think, the pressure for personal growth. You feel like if you're solo traveling, you can't just have a normal trip. There has to be some greater personal
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。做你学到的任何事。都很艰难，即使它有它的好处。你知道的，那些在20岁时经常独自旅行的人，多半会告诉你这是多么有回报。但如果你深入挖掘，他们可能会建议你做好心理准备的其他事情本质上是孤独、决策疲劳、精疲力竭、对未知的恐惧、也许还有安全隐患、以及想要提前回家。同时，我认为还有来自个人成长的压力。你会觉得如果你在独自旅行，你就不能只来一次普通的旅行。似乎必须有一个你正在努力实现的更伟大的个人
development goal that you are striving towards, some epiphany that needs to be had before you return home so that you can come home a changed person. So it doesn't sound like a challenge, but I think it kind of is because it influences the mindset that we bring into the trip. Let's walk through some of these challenges and how to feel more confident addressing them. Something that has always been comforting to me is that there have been thousands of people before me in this exact experience who have experienced the same sensations, the same anxieties and worries, and they've pushed through. They've always come back with more good stories than bad.
发展目标，在回家之前需要有一种顿悟，这样你才能以一个改变了的人的身份回到家中。所以这听起来可能不像是一个挑战，但我认为它确实算是一个挑战，因为它会影响我们带入旅行的心态。让我们来看看其中的一些挑战以及如何更有信心地应对它们。一直以来给我带来安慰的一件事是，在我之前有成千上万的人经历过这种完全相同的体验，他们经历过相同的感受、相同的焦虑和担忧，但他们都挺过来了。他们带回来的好故事总是比坏故事多。
And also, you know, the best place to grow is right when you start feeling a little bit uncomfortable. You don't need to be so insanely uncomfortable that you want to leave. but a bit of discomfort, that's really stretching you as a person. And with that stretch, you grow. You know, without tension, without friction, nothing will ever challenge you. So I think the biggest thing that we are going to confront that will challenge us is loneliness. Without the companionship of friends or family, I think we feel quite isolated, especially in an unfamiliar environment when we don't even have those kind of small creature
而且，你知道的，最好的成长地方恰恰是你开始感到有点不舒服的时候。你不需要感到极度不舒服以至于想要离开。但一点点的不舒服，真的能作为一个人来磨炼你。而正是通过这种磨炼，你才会成长。你知道的，没有紧张感，没有摩擦，没有什么能真正挑战你。所以我认为我们将面对的最大挑战就是孤独。没有朋友或家人的陪伴，我认为我们会感到相当孤立，尤其是在一个不熟悉的环境中，甚至连那些小小的物质
comforts, there are definitely many times when you think it would be really nice to share this with someone. Or you go to sleep at the end of the day and you realize like, huh, I haven't actually said a word to anyone else this entire day. And it feels definitely very odd. But the loneliness can also be a really sacred and special element of this experience. For one, it's definitely the price you pay for more freedom. But additionally, you know, you get to really zone in on your inner world. There was a study done that assessed the importance of having this kind of alone time, not just when traveling, but in your everyday life and it assessed a sample of 150 people. And what it did was it asked them to prioritize spending an hour alone for three weeks, only three weeks,
慰藉都没有时，你肯定会有很多次觉得如果能跟某个人分享这一切该多好。或者你在一天结束时上床睡觉，然后意识到，呃，这一整天我其实没有对任何人说过一句话。这种感觉确实非常奇怪。但孤独也可以成为这段经历中非常神圣和特殊的一个元素。一方面，这绝对是你为获得更多自由而付出的代价。但此外，你知道的，你可以真正专注于你的内心世界。曾有一项研究评估了拥有这种独处时间的重要性，不仅是在旅行时，在你的日常生活中也是如此，该研究评估了150人的样本。它的做法是要求他们优先考虑连续三周每天花一个小时独处，仅仅三周，
an hour every day. So those who did this, those who went through with it, they felt so much more introspective, they actually had more social energy, they felt more in touch with themselves. Some people are never going to get that. You know, the noises and the voices they hear in their head, they will never just be their own. Like imagine that, imagine spending your whole life, never knowing what you would think or do or see or believe if no one else was there. And if you solo travel, you will never have to wonder that. You will never have to wonder. Also, just because you solo travel doesn't mean you need to solitary travel. Like there's a big distinction here between being completely solitary and isolated and just
每天一个小时。所以那些做到这一点的人，那些坚持下来的人，他们感到内心更加平和，他们实际上拥有更多的社交活力，他们感觉自己与内心的联系更紧密了。有些人永远无法体验到这一点。你知道的，他们脑海中听到的噪音和声音，永远不会仅仅属于他们自己。想象一下，想象一下度过你的一生，却永远不知道如果没有别人的存在，你会怎么想、怎么做、怎么看、怎么相信。如果你独自旅行，你就永远不必去猜测这一点。你永远不必去猜测。此外，仅仅因为你独自旅行并不意味着你需要孤立地旅行。这其中有很大的区别，完全孤立、与世隔绝和只是
going into the trip alone. So book a group tour for a day. Stay in a social hostel. Even if you have your own room or you're in a smaller bunk space, you could travel with someone that you meet for a few days and then leave them at your next destination. So don't fall into the trap of believing that the purpose of this trip is to be isolated. it's definitely not, it's just to be self-directed. I also find that people who start travel Instagrams love that, love that for them.
一个人开始旅行是两码事。所以你可以预订一天的团队游。住在社交青旅里。即使你有自己的房间或者你住在较小的铺位空间里，你也可以和你认识的人一起旅行几天，然后在你的下一个目的地离开他们。所以不要陷入这样一种陷阱：认为这次旅行的目的是为了与世隔绝。绝对不是，它只是为了让你能够自主掌控。我也发现那些开通旅行Instagram账号的人非常喜欢这样做，他们很享受这一点。
I love seeing people's like photo dumps of where they are. And when you're a solo traveler, it means that you do still feel connected to people back home. You don't feel like people are forgetting about you. You don't feel as lonely. You can still have that kind of ongoing communication with people about what you are experiencing, what you are learning. Another big thing that we face that I don't actually hear talked about a lot is decision fatigue. Making every single choice for yourself, every single day, from, you know, what am I going to eat, what sites am I going to see, where am I going to stay, how am I going to get there?
我很喜欢看大家发布的关于他们身处何地的照片合集。当你是一个独自旅行者时，这意味着你仍然与家乡的人保持着联系。你不会觉得人们把你遗忘了。你不会感到那么孤独。你仍然可以与他人就你正在经历的事情、你正在学习的东西进行这种持续的沟通。我们要面对的另一个重大问题，是我实际上很少听到人们谈论的，那就是决策疲劳。每天都要为自己做出每一个选择，从，你知道的，我要吃什么，我要看什么景点，我要住在哪里，我要怎么去那里？
That can be exhausting. And solo travelers often face more decisions, not just logistical decisions, but also spontaneous decisions day in and day out. So our cognitive capacity for making decisions is actually rather limited. Each choice you are going to make, no matter how small, it does deplete your mental energy. And what's more is that, you know, everyday environment, you know, when you're at home, you make basically the same choices every day. You take the same route home from work. You have the same routine.
这可能会让人精疲力竭。独自旅行者经常要面对更多的决策，不仅是后勤决策，还有日复一日自发的临时决策。因此，我们做出决策的认知能力其实是相当有限的。你将要做的每一个选择，无论多么微小，都会消耗你的心理能量。更何况，你知道的，在日常环境中，你知道的，当你在家时，你每天基本上都在做相同的选择。你走同一条路回家下班。你有相同的日常。
You go to the same gym, the same cafes. Everything is typically familiar. And so when you are traveling by yourself, things that we teach, typically wouldn't have to think about, like, how do I catch the train? How do I pay for the train? What's on the menu? You know, suddenly we have to think a little bit harder about those things, and that is going to contribute to your cognitive overload. This can definitely make us more tired, a little bit irritable at times, anxious. But the worst thing, the worst consequence of this, I believe at least, is that it can lead to indecision and avoidance. I don't know if you've
你去同一个健身房，去同一家咖啡馆。一切通常都是熟悉的。所以当你独自旅行时，有些我们通常不需要思考的事情，比如，我怎么坐火车？我怎么为火车票付钱？菜单上有什么？你知道的，突然之间我们不得不对这些事情多动一点脑筋，这将会加剧你的认知过载。这绝对会让我们感到更加疲倦，有时会有点烦躁，感到焦虑。但我认为最糟糕的事情，最严重的后果，至少在我看来，是它会导致优柔寡断和逃避。我不知道你是否
ever found yourself in this situation before at home, but you know when you just have so many options of what you could do in a day, you know, you could do chores, you could see a friend, you could go to the gym, go out for dinner, and because you have so many options, you're just like, I just don't want to do any of them. You know, it's not possible to decide which one would be best, so I'm just not going to make a decision at all. That can happen when you're traveling. And the consequence of decision fatigue in this environment is that actually you feel quite let down. You feel like you should be seeing more. The easiest way to counteract this is to actually do the counterintuitive thing and give yourself less choice. I know we speak about, you know, solo traveling and talk about how it's all
曾在家里陷入过这种状况，但你知道当你对一天中能做的事情有太多选择时，你知道的，你可以做家务，你可以见朋友，你可以去健身房，出去吃晚餐，正因为你有太多的选择，你就会想：我其实什么都不想做。你知道的，不可能决定哪一个最好，所以我索性什么决定都不做了。这种情况在旅行时也会发生。在这种环境下，决策疲劳的后果实际上是让你感到相当沮丧。你会觉得你应该看到更多。抵消这种状况最简单的方法，实际上是做一些反直觉的事情，那就是给自己更少的选择。我知道我们谈论，你知道的，独自旅行，并谈论它是多么地
about freedom, but imposing some restrictions on yourself may actually mean you get more out of it. you know, eating breakfast at the same places every day or having that breakfast spot, that's really smart because that's one decision that isn't going to overload you cognitively and you can use that mental energy, those resources to make a better decision. The other thing that I do is that I make a list of 10 things. When I go on a trip, say the trip is two weeks long, I make a list of 10 things that I really want to do. And I make a rough itinerary that still leaves me like, three to four days of having nothing scheduled, but during those days, I know kind of what I'm
关乎自由，但在自己身上施加一些限制实际上可能意味着你能从中获得更多。你知道的，每天在同一个地方吃早餐，或者锁定那个吃早餐的地点，这真的很明智，因为这是一个不会让你产生认知过载的决定，你可以利用这些心理能量、这些资源来做出更好的决定。我做的另一件事是列一个包含10件事的清单。当我进行一次旅行，比方说旅行持续两周，我就会列出10件我真正想做的事。我制定了一个大致的行程，但仍然给我留出大约三到四天没有任何安排的时间，但在这些日子里，我大致知道我要
going to do. I have a loose plan, and I make sure that things are in the same area. So once I'm out of the house, there is kind of a continuity between where I'm going and my experiences. I also think it's really important here when you're facing decision fatigue. Often that comes from a sensation or a deep feeling that you need to make the perfect decision, right? This is such a sacred experience. You're solo traveling. You're in this new country. There's so much to do. I don't want to miss out. I want to make sure that I come back with a good story. I want to make sure that I see everything, do everything. What do I do first? Don't aim for perfection. Even people who live in their cities, their whole lives never see half the things that you want to see. So just know that actually some of the best experiences do come from being quite spontaneous. They do come from just getting out of the house with no plan or just choosing one thing to really focus on for the day. This is not an assignment. This is not a piece of work.
做什么。我有一个松散的计划，并且我确保这些事情都在同一个区域。因此，一旦我出门，我要去的地方和我的体验之间就会有一种连贯性。我还认为，当你面对决策疲劳时，这一点非常重要。这通常源于一种观念或深层感觉，即你需要做出完美的决定，对吧？这是一次如此神圣的经历。你在独自旅行。你在一个新的国家。有那么多事情要做。我不想错过。我要确保我能带回一个好故事。我要确保我看到了一切，做了一切。我该先做什么？不要追求完美。即使是在他们的城市生活了一辈子的本地人，也永远看不到你想看的一半事物。所以要知道，实际上一些最好的体验恰恰来自于相当随性的时刻。它们确实来自于毫无计划地出门，或者仅仅选择一件事在当天真正专注于它。这不是一项作业。这不是一份工作。
This is not anything that needs to be perfect for someone else to judge or for someone else to see. It's actually really fascinating. We talk about decision fatigue and how it can be really hard for solo travelers. But actually, when solo travelers return home, they report how difficult it is to adjust to having to consider other people. Because you're so used to being self-directed in these environments, you come back and your family's like, let's go out for breakfast
这不是任何需要做到完美以供别人评判或别人观看的东西。这其实真的很有趣。我们谈论决策疲劳以及它对独自旅行者来说如何会非常艰难。但实际上，当独自旅行者回到家中时，他们会诉说适应必须照顾到别人的感受有多么困难。因为你已经习惯了在这些环境中由自己主导，当你回来时，你的家人说，我们出去吃早餐吧
and you're like, great, we're going to go here. And suddenly it's like, no, no, I want to go here. I want to go there. And it can actually be quite frustrating for solo travelers. It's often this sense of like a shock of returning to a system or returning to a situation or an environment in which you do actually now have to consider other people again. So the final difficulty I think we face when,
而你会说，太好了，我们要去这里。而突然之间对方会说，不，不，我想去这里。我想去那里。这实际上会给独自旅行者带来相当大的挫败感。这通常是一种震惊感，仿佛重新回到了一个系统，或者重新回到了一个你现在确实必须再次考虑其他人的情况或环境中。因此，我认为我们在考虑独自探索时面临的最后困难，
contemplating solo exploring. It's a deeply human one and it's a fear of the unknown. And with that can come a heavy dose of catastrophizing, right? This is the biggest thing that I think people bring up when you say, you should solo travel. Solo travel is so worthwhile. It's what if I'm kidnapped? What if I get lost? What if I get robbed? What if something terrible happens? What if no one knows where I am? Our brain takes the unknown and it likes to make a mess of it, likes to make it its little fantasy playground. of all the worst things possible that our brain can conjure up. That is anxiety. That is a survival mechanism.
是一个非常人性化的困难，那就是对未知的恐惧。随之而来的可能是大量的灾难化思维，对吧？每当你提到“你应该独自旅行，独自旅行非常值得”时，这往往是人们提出的最大问题。如果我被绑架了怎么办？如果我迷路了怎么办？如果我被抢劫了怎么办？如果发生了可怕的事情怎么办？如果没人知道我在哪里怎么办？我们的大脑面对未知时，喜欢把它搞得一团糟，喜欢把它当作自己想象力的游乐园，
It is not the truth. I want you to remember, though, it is a very valid concern. Safety is a valid concern. But everything in life is a risk. There is fear embedded in everything that we do, even getting out of bed, even walking out of our front door. You though, you were not put on this earth to play it safe. And you were not put on this earth to only go where it's
充斥着大脑能想象到的所有最糟糕的事情。这就是焦虑。这是一种生存机制。它并不是事实。不过，我想让你记住，这是一个非常合理的担忧。安全是一个合理的担忧。但生活中的一切都是有风险的。我们做的每一件事都内含着恐惧，甚至连起床、甚至走出前门都是如此。然而，你来到这个世界并不是为了求稳。你来到这个世界也不是为了只去那些感到舒适的地方，
comfortable because that would mean that you really never grow you never move from where you are now things can go wrong they do grow wrong but when you have your wits about you when you do the common sense things you still are a lot more capable than you know and the very nature of solo travelling is to show you that you know what you're doing that you are capable strong independent you have that mental toughness, you have that adaptability, that flexibility. So those experiences and the thought of those experiences can be scary. But firstly, you're very unlikely to encounter them. Secondly, when you do, you will realize that you are a lot more capable in that moment.
因为那意味着你永远不会成长，你永远不会从现在的地方有所前进。事情可能会出错，它们也确实会出错，但当你保持清醒的头脑，当你做那些符合常理的事情时，你其实比自己想象的要更有能力，而独自旅行的本质就是向你证明你知道自己在做什么，你有能力、坚强、独立，你拥有那种精神坚韧度，你拥有那种适应力和灵活性。因此，这些经历以及对这些经历的想法可能会令人感到害怕。但首先，你极不可能遭遇这些情况。其次，当你真正遇到时，你会发现在那一刻自己其实更有能力应对。
It's not as scary as you thought it would be. And I think finally, when you have common sense, when you just do basic safety things, like having an anti-pick pocket bag, registering with your embassy, telling people where you're going, a lot of that risk is definitely minimized. So I want to finish up with just some general advice, some fast, rapid fire tips from me to you, but also from some of the audience, some of the listeners who are solo traveler pros. This piece of advice, I believe in 100%. it's to set intentions, not expectations.
它并没有你想象的那么可怕。最后我认为，当你运用常识，当你只是做一些基本的安全防范措施时，比如使用防偷包、向你的大使馆登记、告诉别人你要去哪里，很大一部分风险绝对会被降到最低。所以我想以一些一般的建议来结束，一些从我给你们的快速连珠炮式的建议，同时也来自一些观众、一些身为独自旅行专家的听众的建议。这个建议，我百分之百相信。那就是：设定意图，而不是设定期望。
When you have really high expectations for something, you are always going to be disappointed, not because the experiences are better or worse, but because your expectations tint your perspective. They tint how you see things. So focus on what you're hoping to learn, what you're hoping to experience, what you're hoping to get out of it emotionally and psychologically,
当你对某事抱有非常高的期望时，你总是会感到失望，这并不是因为经历更好或更糟，而是因为你的期望给你的视角涂上了底色。它们给你的所见所闻着了色。所以，与其死板地规划每一个细节，例如在巴黎时心里想着“我必须去埃菲尔铁塔，我必须看它灯火辉煌的样子，因为这在我的愿望清单上，而且它会美丽神奇，一切都必须完美”，不如专注于你希望学到什么，你希望经历什么，你希望从中获得什么情感和心理上的收获，
rather than rigidly planning every detail and being like, you know if you're in Paris like I have to go to the Apple Tower and I have to see it lit up because that's on my bucket list and it's going to be beautiful and magical and everything needs to be perfect your expectations are too high set them low be like I just want to have a nice time I want to have a nice meal I want to meet some new people I want to walk around I want to see a sunset more general ideas of what the trip could be so don't plan everything remember that you have freedom so if you you're not enjoying where you are, if you're not enjoying your accommodation, you're not enjoying the country, the city, the suburb, the neighborhood that you're in, move on. You don't have to
因为你的期望太高了。把期望调低一点，告诉自己：“我只是想度过一段美好的时光，我想吃一顿美餐，我想结识一些新朋友，我想四处走走，我想看一场日落”——对旅行可能会是什么样有一个更宽泛的想法。所以不要把一切都计划得死死的。记住你拥有自由，所以如果你不喜欢你所在的地方，如果你不喜欢你的住处，不喜欢你所在的国家、城市、郊区、社区，那就搬迁吧。你不需要
ask anyone for permission. That's the beauty of this. If you are not having fun, just leave. And I always say this, you know, it can be hard when you've already paid for a hotel, you've paid for an experience. This is what I always say. You can either waste your money and do something else or you can waste your money and your time. And that is a double whammy. You can waste your money while, you know, you're still doing an experience. You're still staying somewhere you don't enjoy and you've already spent the money on the thing. But then you're also wasting your time because you could have been using those hours, those days to be somewhere else, somewhere better, somewhere that you may have enjoyed more. Rest, please, take a break. I did an episode, I think at the start of
征求任何人的许可。这就是它的美妙之处。如果你玩得不开心，直接离开就行。我总是这样说，你知道的，当你已经为酒店付过钱，为某个体验付过钱时，这可能会很难。我总是这样说：要么你浪费了钱却去做了别的事，要么你既浪费了钱又浪费了时间。而那是双重打击。你可以一边浪费着钱（你知道的，你仍然在进行某项体验，你仍然住在某个你并不喜欢的住处，而且你已经为之花过钱了），但同时你也在浪费时间，因为你本可以利用那些小时、那些天去别的地方，去一个更好的地方，去一个你可能会更喜欢的地方。休息一下，请休息一下。我想我在今年初做过一期关于
the year on travel burnout for people who solo travel a lot. it's a real thing. You put a lot of pressure on yourself to be go, go, go, you've spent all this money. You want to see everything, do everything, taste everything. It sounds strange. Rest will make those experiences better. My general rule is that for every four days that you are doing something, take one day to do nothing. Take one day or even a half day to just walk around, take it easy, have a nice meal, have a sleep in.
经常独自旅行的人的旅行倦怠的节目。这是真实存在的。你给自己施加了很大的压力，要求自己必须马不停蹄、一刻不停，你花光了所有的钱。你想要看到一切、做一切、品尝一切。这听起来可能很奇怪，但休息会让那些体验变得更好。我的大致规则是：你每进行四天的活动，就抽一天什么也不做。抽一天甚至半天时间四处闲逛、放轻松、吃顿大餐、睡个懒觉。
it will really mean that you get more out of the trip. And finally, bring a journal along and try and do an entry every night or every morning reflecting on the previous experiences. This is a really great way to see how you're growing, to remember the realizations that you're having when you get home. It's also just a great historical document to have the older you get. I think about this all the time, you know, my kids being able to read what I've written, a museum getting a hold of it, maybe some future human finding it tucked into a drawer of some antique
这确实意味着你能从旅行中收获更多。最后，随身带一本手记，尽量每天晚上或每天早上写一篇日记，反思前一天的经历。这是观察自己如何成长、记住回家后那些顿悟的好方法。随着你年龄的增长，它也是一份极好的历史文献。我经常想这件事，你知道的，我的孩子能够阅读我写下的东西，博物馆会收藏它，也许某个未来的发现在某件古董家具的抽屉深处发现了它（虽然那家具可能来自宜家，但他们并不知道）。我很喜欢这种想法，即我所拥有的记忆变得具有了某种永恒性。所以我真的鼓励你，去买一本精美的手记并好好利用它。我希望你喜欢这一集。我希望我已经为你在20岁时独自旅行提出了一个令人信服的论点，同时，如果你是一个独自旅行者，我也为你提供了一些鼓励，告诉你该如何在那些艰难的日子里应对，为什么最后这一切都是值得的，以及如何提升这种体验。这绝对是我深信我们都应该去做的事，哪怕它只是去离家两个小时的露营之旅。希望它在某种程度上是每个人都能触及并实现的。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请确保留下评论，留下评价，如果你能大发慈悲的话，最好是一个五星好评。我确实会阅读你们大家说的每一句话。这让我的一整天都充满阳光。我每天都要花几分钟或20分钟左右的时间来浏览新的评价，阅读你们留在Spotify上的评论。所以感谢所有提供反馈、告诉我们你们想法的人。请确保也在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。你可以了解更多我们在节目中谈论的主题。我们会进行更深入的探讨。
piece of furniture that's probably from IKEA, but they don't know that. Like, I really like that idea of the memories that I've had taking on some permanence. So I would really encourage you, get a really nice journal and use it. I hope that you've enjoyed this episode. I hope that I've made a compelling argument for solo traveling in your 20s and also giving you a bit of a pep talk if you are someone who's solo travel. on what to do on those hard days, why it's all worth it at the end, how to elevate the experience. It genuinely is something that I deeply believe that we should all do, even if it's just going
我们会讨论一些相关的研究。我会给你们
on a camping trip two hours away from home. It's accessible and available to everyone, hopefully in some capacity. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, make sure that you leave a comment, you leave a review, hopefully a five-star review, if you would be so kind. I do read everything that you guys say. It makes my day. I spend like a couple of minutes or like 20 minutes every day just reading through the new reviews, reading through the comments you guys are leaving on Spotify. So thank you to all of you who are giving feedback, telling us what you think. Make sure you are also following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. You can learn more about the topics that we talk about on the show. We go more in depth.
选择新剧集的选项，以倾听你们的意见并讨论你们的经历。所以我们非常希望能在那里见到你们。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良。请对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方其实都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你们是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身西装和坚硬的防备四处走动？
We talk about some of the studies. And I give you. the options to choose new episodes to give your import to talk about your experiences. So we would love to see you over there. And until next time, stay safe, stay kind. And please be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored.
这向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件，并揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and. Michael Rancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在你这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《2%》。这就是《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个高产的诈骗犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个iHeart播客。播客。真人保证。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Podcasts. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。